. Let's go.
Why don't we go next?
Oh, there's just so many people who are interested
in in getting on today.
Why don't we go to Sean from College Station,
come back on him.
Yes, I can.
My apologies.
I had my keyboard on the floor.
Oh, my.
How does the keyboard even get on the floor?
I have a small son and he loves to play with
my keyboard.
Oh, gosh.
All right.
Well, what's going on?
Not too much.
So I had a quick question I've asked a couple
times before, but I know you get tons of questions.
How would you feel about trying a Medicare
for all in the same way that they're doing
the electoral vote compact?
So, for example, we know the states are signing
up.
And once we get to a certain number of states
or certain number of electoral votes, that's
when the the law will kick in.
I hear a lot of people complain with Medicare
for all on the state level that, oh, well,
then a bunch of people are going to move to
that state and you're going to have you know,
it's going to be so overloaded in that state
that there is no way any one state could handle
it.
So what if what would you feel about like
maybe some sort of interstate or interstate
compact where, OK, once we have a certain
number of the population, you know, so there's
a couple of different there's a couple of
different issues there.
OK, the first one is.
Because, you know, the national popular national
popular vote interstate compact is not really
analogous to what you're suggesting with Medicare
for all, because it is just a completely different
thing.
And there's no way that if enough states do
Medicare for all, you all of a sudden have
federal Medicare for all.
I think the idea of starting Medicare for
all within one state is a great idea.
Vermont tried to do it a few years ago and
they ultimately were not able to the the question
of people moving to that states it'll become
a problem more because of the supply of medical
services.
Financially, it shouldn't be a problem, because
if people move to that state, they'll be paying
taxes to the state, which will support the
program.
OK, so that's the concern is less about people
moving from a financial standpoint.
It's that it'll create demand for way more
doctors and presumably some doctors will move
there as well.
So let's keep thinking about that.
I'm going to let you go because it really
sounds like you have your hands very, very
full there with your son.
Very much appreciate the call.
Let's take a quick break.
If you're holding, don't hang up, because
we're going right back to the phones momentarily.
The David Pakman Show at David Pakman Dotcom.
Welcome back to The David Pakman Show.
All right, let's hear from a few more folks
via The David Pakman Show Discord server,
which you can find at David Pakman dot com
slash discord.